hallo ihr lieben ich bin richtig
aufgeregt heute gibt es eines meiner top
5 lieblingsrezepte die mit schokolade zu
tun haben wer mich kennt weiß ich liebe
schokolade über alles und wenn es euch
genauso geht dann passt jetzt gut auch
bei diesem rezept das ultra lecker wir
machen einen schokoladen lava kuchen das
heißt die schokolade wird aus unserem
kuchen raus fließen in flüssiger form
mega lecker mit einer kugel eis oder
auch anderen variationen ich zeige euch
hier zuallererst die zutaten
wir benötigen sagt peter kuvertüre in
feine stücke geschnitten außerdem butter
zucker hier habe ich noch ein bisschen
vanille zucker und mehl
wir starten jetzt in dem wir kuvertüre
und butter schmelzen
ich mach das ungern direkt im topf weil
das kann sein dass die butter verbrennen
schokolade verbrennt und um das zu
verhindern habe ich hier im wasserbad
gemacht einfach im topf mit etwas wasser
befüllt aufkochen lassen und dann lasse
ich das auf mittlerer stufe weiter
köcheln und das daneben kuvertüre und
butter darin schmelzen
[Musik]
so die butter schokolade ist vollständig
geschmolzen ein weiterer wichtiger
schritt ist jetzt das ganze zur seite zu
geben rund 15 bis 20 minuten zu warten
dass es abkühlt denn dann können wir es
weiter machen werden die schokolade
butter masse jetzt richtig schön
auskühlt nutzen wir die zwischenzeitig
habe erstens den ofen vorgeheizt auf 200
grad ober und unterhitze und zwar ins
meine tassen jetzt parat gelegt wer wie
ich keine so filmchen hat der hilft sich
einfach damit weiter und das hat bei mir
immer wunderbar funktioniert bisher
wir nehmen uns jetzt einfach weiche
butter und einem pinsel und dann hätten
wir das erst mal vom boden und von den
seiten her richtig schön ein
so nachdem wir das erledigt habt einfach
ein bisschen backpapier auf den boden
geben ich habe das jetzt hier und
ausgeschnitten perfekt für den boden der
tasse und das hilft eben dass wir unser
showküche ein später richtig schön aus
der form bekommen
[Musik]
so die förmchen sind vorbereitet unsere
schoko butter massiv abgekühlt und jetzt
machen wir weiter in einer neuen
separaten schüssel gebe ich jetzt
zuallererst die einreiben mit dem zucker
und dann nehme ich mir ein schneebesen
und schlag das so ein bisschen bis ich
alles verbindet und das ist ja auch
wieder das geniale wir brauchen keine
küchenmaschine
[Musik]
eier und zucker haben sich gut
miteinander verbunden und jetzt gebe ich
in einem dünnen strahl die abgekühlte
kuvertüre futtermischung reiz und dann
ruhig das auch noch mal gut unter so
sobald die schokolade auch mit
eingearbeitet wurde gehen wir noch das
mehl hinzu backpulver hat bei diesem
rezept nicht zu suchen dass wir nicht so
förderlich für unseren shop kern und das
mehl sie wie ich jetzt noch mal zur
sicherheit
so dass mail hat sich jetzt gut
verbunden mit den restlichen zutaten der
teig ist fertig und jetzt fühlen wir den
nun auch ein in unsere förmchen und zwar
machen weil es nicht ganz voll also
nicht bis zum anschlag denn die gehen
noch ein bisschen hoch
[Musik]
meine tasten sind jetzt drei viertel
voll und so gebe es jetzt in den
vorgeheizten backofen wichtig ist dass
der vorgeheizt ist weil 200 grad ober
und unterhitze 14 bis 18 minuten bei der
backzeit noch ein ganz kurzer hinweis
das kann sehr stark variieren und ich
mache das immer so jetzt kind
mittlerweile mein ofen aber anfangs
hatte ich so gemacht sagt sie man erst
rausgenommen mal nach 14 minuten noch 15
8 16
und dann immer einen angeschnitten und
dann habe ich geschaut ob es geklappt
hat und wenn ihr den flüssigen kern sie
dann könnt ihr euch nämlich die minuten
merken und dann klappt es immer also bis
gleich
[Musik]
bei mir gab es heute dazu eine kugel
vanilleeis und frische minze sonst mag
ich auch gerne sorbet frische früchte
oder pürierte früchte das könnt ihr euch
dann immer aussuchen
ich freue mich findet dieses rezept
gefallen hat nie genannt angaben
schreibt sich wie immer unten in die
infobox hinterlässt man gerne ein
kostenloses abo dann verpasst ja auch
nichts mehr und bleibt dieses video
fleißig damit unterstützte mich nämlich
ich freue mich auf eure fotos mit dem
hashtag s kitchen auf instagram und dann
seitlich bis zum nächsten mal auf die
skizzen tschüss